من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي السيد اللواء بماذا
هذه الاستماته الذي حيث تتمسك اوكرانيا في
باق موت رغم التكلفه الكبيره كما يقول
المراقبون العسكريون
يعني اولا القرار السياسي حيث القرار
السياسي قبل تقريبا اسبوع
تحدثت نائب وزير الدفاع وقالت لقد تم
اناطه الامر واتخاذ القرار حول معركه
باقمه القاده العسكريين ولكن بعد اجتماع
القائد الجيش الاوكراني مع الرئيس
اتفقا على ان لا يتم الانسحاب وان يتم
القتال من خلال معركه استنزاف مضنيه
للجانب الروسي وان كانت كذلك مؤلمه للجانب
الاوكراني
لتجنب منح القوات الروسيه نصر معنوي قد
يكون له انعكاساته الايجابيه على الجانب
الروسي والانعكاسات السلبيه على الجانب
الاوكراني وهذا الموقف هو يعتبر احد نقاط
الخلاف مع مع القياده الامريكيه حيث
التوصيات والنصائح الامريكيه بالتخلي عنها
وبالتالي هي معركه استنزاف
بمقاربتين المقاربه الاولى الدفاع عن
الجزء الغربي غرب نهر خاتوفكا رغم حدوث
اختراقات من الشرق والجنوب من قبل قوات
فاجنر باتجاه المنطقه
المربع الامني او القيادي او الاداري
الجزء
الاخر ولا تقل اهميه وخطوره وهو محاوله
الحفاظ على الطريق الوحيد والطرق عبر
الضواحي مفتوحه خارج اطار السيطره الناريه
للقوات الروسيه لتسمح بالانسحاب اذا كان
لا مفر منه وللسماح بوصول التعزيزات
في البدايه
التشبت بباخ ولاسباب سياسيه ولكن ماذا عن
اهميتها الاستراتيجيه
الاهميه الاستراتيجيه في حال سقوطها يعتمد
يعتمد على ماذا فعل الاوكران في الخط
الدفاعي الجديد هناك خط دفاعي اول انتهى
في 2014 وخد دفاع ثاني تعتبر
حجر الزاوي في وخط الدفاع الثالث الخط
الذي يقع وطوله 100 كلم يقع امام سلافيا
نسخ اكراماتوريسك وبالتالي مدى جاهزيه
الخط الدفاعي الثالث اذا كانت تم اعداده
فهي ليست ذات قيمه استراتيجيه من وجهه نظر
عسكريه اما اذا كان هذا الخط لا يزال في
طور تشكيل ولم تصل التعزيزات سيكون نجاح
عملياتي كبير يفضي الى تداعيات قد يكون
صعب
احتوائها من قبل الجانب الاوكراني ولكن
اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين قطعوا شوطا كبيرا في
بناء الخط الدفاعي المعزز بالخنادق
والانفاق وينتظروا بناء القوه من خلال
وصول الدبابات الغربيه من اجل التحضير له
هجوم الربيع هل تعتقد بان امدادات
العسكريه للقوات الاوكرانيه
ستستمر رغم الى الاختلاف في وجهات النظر
حول اهميه باخمت
هذا الاختلاف لا يرقى لا يرقى الى المستوى
الاستراتيجي او السياسي هو اختلاف على
المستوى التكتيكي والعملياتي تحديدا في
البعد العسكري الخلاف يتمثل في اكثر من
نقطه يتمثل فيها اولا تقديم النصيحه وعدم
الاستجابه يتمثل في طريقه اداره المعركه
الجانب الاوكراني يعتمد المقاربه الروسيه
والسوفيتيه الافراط الغير المعقول في
استخدام الذخيره وبالتالي هذا بدا يشكل
عبئا على الخطوع خطوط الذخيره الاول
الثاني والثالث في امريكا والدول
الاوروبيه وبالتالي هم ينصحوهم بعدم
الافراط في استهلاك الذخيره لان المخزونات
والانتاج قد لا يلبي الاحتياجات لفتره
طويله جدا لذا عليهم ان يعيدوا النظر في
اداره الحرب وليس اداره المعركه بحيث تبني
العقيده القتالي الغربيه التي
تعتمد على مقاربه العمليات الاحاطه
والتطويق والاختراقات العميقه وكسب
المعارك من خلال المناوره اكثر من كسبها
من خلال الافراط في استخدام الذخيره شكرا
لك
العسكري والاستراتيجي متحدثا من عمان شكرا